I have a question who do you think are
the biggest vowel white racist the media
you think the media is racist
what please next question please don't
ask me any [ __ ] questions
okay let me go to the the next at the
barbershop and everything I used to hear
like people always about man you know
when I want to Entertainer get on of
course you know he gonna go and get a
white girl involving all this
but I want to say that you know and the
white girl don't go get a rich black
dude and you know right but I want to
say that my wife
has dated broke black dudes
[Applause]
George Bush doesn't care about black
people
in the past few days they cut right away
from him my advice he looked like
what Mike Myers hurt his neck he turned
and he's like what did you just his
faces did you just say that you so
famously and so powerfully said George
Bush doesn't care about black people it
makes me wonder what makes you think
that Donald Trump does or any people at
all
why don't we take a break we'll come
back and uh Kanye West I was supposed to
work with Madonna and uh I went over a
house and we were joking about the Tesla
sky video and I told her I used Pamela
Anderson because I grew up on her she
helped you know make me a
alternative man you know looked like
McDonald's getting a little jealous I
was like no no I used to jack off to you
too
I'm with you yeah it's in the building
[Applause]
put your hands in the air right now yeah
my dad ain't had to do one thing for me
he only had to do one thing nut you
ain't gotta do nothing yeah that's all
my dad ever had to do was nut
he ain't gonna ask me for nothing else
I say to specify the business people
that have raped my people that just so
happen to be Jewish
I think what by doing what you've just
done I find that I'm not even Jewish and
I find that offensive why do you keep
having to do that I don't think you get
it at all I know you understand I almost
borderline like being sued because it's
the only time where I can be myself
because I sit in those depositions and
it'd be hilarious I mean I was in a
deposition with Suge Knight and I had my
hand my hands on my face like this right
and the lawyer was sitting shook sitting
right there and shug's lawyer sitting
next to me he said um uh can you uh
can you take your hands off your face no
I said take your hands off your face
I'll look down take your hands off your
face I said look sir you're gonna have
to ask me nicely to take my hands off my
face please talk to me with some type of
respect and he says okay Mr West can you
please take your hands off your face and
I said
no
Kanye you're back after six years are
you happy to be back and performing
tonight much anticipated performance
with Paul McCartney and Rihanna I'm just
extremely happy can you tell by my face
Kanye is a producer that's how you
started the music business wasn't it
well that's because no one wanted to let
me rap because you know I didn't have a
gun on me or you know uh and I didn't
dress like in throwback jerseys and all
this and my clothes fit you know
you're doing this thing where you're
bringing to people together and you know
that's that's pretty good I think
oh I know
and instead I walked away from that
situation I went to Japan like the
samurai that I am and went to the top of
the mountain and
because I knew that I mean I knew there
was no way
she could love this dude not just
because he's ugly he's not black she
likes black guys every guy that she you
know is with looks exactly the same Ray
J uh Reggie Bush
at that time Kanye West she has a type
just like how I have a type like a lot
of my girls look kind of similar to her
because in a video game character people
have people have their type right so I
knew that this was like the princess has
a type and she likes Mario
right 50 Cent has been quoted as saying
that if your album should outsell his he
will never make another album ever again
have you heard him
for a tire once my arm sells the most I
just want him
the Earth uh that what what do you say
the the sun revolved around the earth
right vice versa you know so when you
have modern but the futuristic but this
but I'm not concerned about the specific
sir right right
okay
Saint Vincent but it's pronounced sent
and I knew you were going to see Saint
and go do you remember that when we were
sending tons of names and then you wrote
back I like Saints no
do not act like you don't remember that
we were sending a million names
I deliver
like it's art like I feel like I'm a pop
artist right and a cyborg had to use the
bathroom really really bad and they
didn't give me enough time
um I just want to tell you that so uh
it's Blended so much into what you were
talking about
but I thought you had to use the
bathroom then I have to use the bathroom
really bad right now okay well retired
interview yeah that's okay I feel like
your attitude towards women has changed
since having daughters
nah I still look at PornHub and
yay you're you know a billionaire you
can do what the hell you want I'm just
I'm just saying to you that I don't
think you quite understand when you uh
when you talk about uh okay can I finish
it's not uh multi multi you're a
multi-millionaire okay well
congratulations but that doesn't change
the fact that when you insult the Jewish
people and say you're going Jessica so
when you were cycling in Amsterdam you
didn't could you go up near the red
light district oh yeah I'll visit I'm
I'm a big fan of porn I
when you watch that video of George
Floyd no it's not a butt it's not it's
that I'm not going to watch I I know I
know what you said
sorry
I know what it means
be quiet and let me finish
[Music]
gonna be gonna be when the lights go
down we're down
everybody asked me the question they
want to know
what kind I know he's gonna wow out and
it's gonna do something crazy
everybody want to know what I would do
if I didn't win
I guess we'll never know
[Music]
I need some help
come back
oh my God
[Applause]
no Taylor
I'm really happy for you I'm let you
finish but Beyonce had one of the best
videos of all time
one of the best videos of all time
foreign